I have known Michael Anton for about 25
years something like that we have shared
more Chinese meals and steaks than with
most other people I know alive today
and we're friends and we've been friends
for a long time Michael is the former
deputy national security advisor for
communications under President Trump and
he was the author of the widely read
essay the flight 93 election which Rush
Limbaugh read aloud on the air it was a
clarion call for a vote for Donald Trump
over Hillary Clinton and it was an
attack a brutal aggressive attack on the
conservative movement the what he
described as the ossified conservative
movement and on conservative
intellectuals and I will admit that I
bristled a bit when I read the essay
when he suggested that conservative
media types were making Trump skeptical
arguments because it would get them more
television airtime I didn't do that and
woody wrote and read it carefully you
know are you accusing me of fake news
right now and would grow their bank
accounts he insists that he didn't mean
me though I'm still trying to understand
who else he could have met with his
frequent references to quote the
corpulent bearded graying weekly
standards set the control-f try to find
those words in the essay I think they
will not appear right that is fake news
he did not actually he did not actually
say that here's here's the dirty secret
about me and Mike and that essay we
talked about it for hours and hours and
hours and a lot of these other things it
was published in September I think yeah
we're talking about it in well before
anywhere we back up before the essay
grew out of a blog that I started with
some other guys called the Journal of
American greatness that wasn't online
very long I think February to June of
2016 and for reasons it started to
become notorious all of us were
pseudonymous doing other things and I
think some some of us not so much me I
wanted to keep going just keep
but some others were decided to pull the
plug in June but during the time it was
ongoing Steve was covering the primaries
and would be have long hours in rental
cars driving from Iowa to wherever and
you just get on the cell phone and we'd
argue and I'd make the pro truck case
he'd make the anti-trump case and they
were sort of knife fights you were just
like friendly but really you know what
about this you know what can you say to
that and there were so many times when I
would stump him and he just had no
answer but the he would do the same to
me I just had no answer they would use
what he would have to say and I'm like
yeah that's a good point but I still
think it's all outweighed by everything
over here they were those conversations
that were so useful in sharpening my own
thought and in making sure that you know
I wasn't getting away with anything or
at least getting away with as little as
possible you know to make the the least
lazy the least kind of you know shortcut
the type of hours oh wait are you saying
that I played a role in the intellectual
case for Donald Trump
you did and you know oh so so the other
day I did something like this at AEI
which is a similar similarly well let's
just say when you hear the words like
weekly standard like inviting Trump guy
you start to think this is a firing
squad so that I had criticized AEI a lot
on the journal America greatness and
elsewhere but nonetheless I was invited
to do something sort of like this at AEI
about ten days ago with Steve Hayward
and he Bret he brings up the flight 93
election and said you know Steve you're
actually in a way a spiritual co-author
of the flight 93 election and I say that
because I know a lot of people in this
room hate it and hate me and so
deflecting blame is good and the reason
is was really twofold one is it Steve
through the power line blog was the
first to find the journal of American
greatness and start to publicize it and
second after we pulled the plug and I
said okay I'm never doing that again I
started to stew over the summer and
think like I got to write something and
I'm from California he lives in
California I drove down to his place and
hung out for two days with Hayward and
you know kind of complained allowed and
griped and the essay took shape over the
course of those two days and
conversation with him I drove back to my
hometown of San L I love this fact this
has got to be noted for history the
flight 93 election was written in santa
cruz california and county that was
probably 95 to 5 for Hillary
I hope although I don't want that to be
widely known because I actually still
want to go home every once while I don't
want to be like stopped at the border
but I do find it to be ironic so you
know I drove home and I immediately
wrote the piece after that so yeah in a
way you know you guys are both spiritual
co-authors for different reasons
should I renounce that co-authorship no
I was look it was a provocative essay
obviously it was very I thought it was
well-written I didn't agree with a lot
of it and we can have that we can have
that day we'll have some of that debate
a little bit later what I want to do is
start with the most recent thing you
just came out of the Trump
administration you top spokesman for the
National Security Council you saw this
up close for the past 16 17 months I'd
like to ask you a little bit first about
the bin Laden document so I think this
is something that I think Donald Donald
Trump deserves tremendous credit for you
had a role in that Mike Pompeo was a big
advocate for releasing those documents
how did that release so before becoming
a head of the CIA Mike Pompeo was one of
the senior Republicans on the
Intelligence Committee and and and knows
Tom Jocelin has known him a long time
and had taught Jocelyn and others had
been in his ear you got to use
congressional pressure to get these
documents out which he tried to do and
just got stonewalled so you know I had
been hearing about the middle Aden
document since right after they were
captured Tom would call me all the time
and tell me what he was hearing and what
was going on and it was very interesting
but I thought you know I sympathize but
what the hell can I do all of a sudden
now I'm in a position where maybe I can
do something so I told him well one day
you know I said at the beginning of this
administration if I do only two things
while I'm there it will have been a
success number one is to get the
documents out number two is to make sure
that Tom Johnson gets a senior
counterterrorism position in the US
government so I was one for two he one
day I told Tom I was gonna do this I
used to you know we'd have meetings in
the Situation Room all the time I didn't
know Pompeo at all people come in they
sit around the big table I'm sitting
along the outside chairs and I just as
the meeting broke up I walked right up
to him and I said I'm Mike Anton Tom
Jocelyn is a good friend of mine I bet
you know what I'm gonna say next he says
my log files yes he goes we're working
on it we're gonna get this done
here you know talk to my guys here now
is February as
Tom said it took till November first
there were a lot of bureaucratic twists
and turns were just when you thought you
had it all done and it was about to come
out all of a sudden some stop sign would
flare up you'd have to go back to people
and no no that was not the intent there
were all kinds of ways that the
bureaucracy tried to either slow it down
or stop it or limit it or whatever
Pompeyo was always there to intervene in
the right way so it was HR McMaster so
were some others so we just kept you
know kept pushing pushing pushing and
got it done
I don't want to take the credit for it I
mean I think really if there's one
person who got it done it was definitely
Pompeo but he also had a lot of things
to do and so there were other people
that had to kind of Shepherd through the
details to make sure that it happened
the way he wanted it to happen well it's
it's important that they're out I think
the president deserves credit for it I
think
Pompeyo does I do think you do and we're
learning a lot more there are files that
we have been told about that have been
described to us that we can't find I
mean it is needle-in-a-haystack work tom
is doing the bulk of it and we're
looking for some some more of those
needles and I think they will if they
are as they've been described to us will
generate significant interest and a lot
of news even if the mainstream media
tries to ignore them why did Donald
Trump fire HR McMaster well I think that
it's widely reported I'm I'm not really
giving any giving away any secrets that
the personality-wise they were kind of
oil and water I think that he I think
the president was really upset hurt and
unhappy about what happened to Mike
Flynn both the way it happened that it
happened so quickly and that he was
deprived of him he didn't have a plan B
nobody expects to be losing their
national security advisor after 24 days
and he had to make a decision on the fly
and he was recommended McMaster was
recommended among others by Tom cotton I
think who the president has a lot of
trusted and belief in because Tom cotton
was an army officer under McMaster in
Iraq and you know kind of took a flyer
on a guy he didn't really know and they
just
personality-wise I don't think they ever
they ever meshed I think it got better
but it never got good enough that it was
going to be a long term working
relationship that that you know really
met what the president
this morning on our panel about covering
the covering the Trump White House in
covering Washington I think both bill
and Mike Warren suggested that it was
you know McMasters is a details guy he
likes to go several layers deep and the
president doesn't like to go as deep he
wants it sort of short and sweet is that
there's something to that but there also
was just McMaster I have almost nothing
bad to say about him really nothing bad
to say about him which is when you know
I later would get into some trouble with
certain quarters of the pro-trump right
and thought I was too loyal to McMaster
and that the way I should have done my
job was to be on the inside undermining
him all the time
I found that absurd but McMaster did
unfortunately like it when he was around
us and his staff and his friends he
could be a really freewheeling and fun
guy he could not let that part of him
out in front of the president in front
of the president he was always standing
at attention saying yes or no sir and
what you would see amongst the other
people around the president I could cite
Gary Cohn and some others shoot the
breeze with him and needle him a little
bit and treat him like a regular guy and
he liked that a chart couldn't do that
and he just never got over the the just
sir here this you know here are the
points that you need to know he would
get interrupted in mid-sentence because
Trump likes to interrupt people in
mid-sentence and take the conversation
in a lot of directions and there was a
sense that McMaster was sort of wait
until there was a natural pause and then
he would just pick up that same sentence
again the Trump found that really
annoying I can see where it would be
frustrating from both sides yeah is is
it the case that the president doesn't
like to you said he frequently
interrupts and sort of moves around he
certainly has a reputation of somebody
who doesn't pay very careful attention
to details he makes visceral judgments
he doesn't get bogged down in a lot of
the policy details it's somebody like a
McMaster or maybe a Pompeii or others
briefed him on is that a fair
characterization I guess but then I
would wonder if even if it's a fair
characterization are there is it useful
for a president to get bogged down in
the details isn't that why you have a
staff isn't that why you have subject
matter experts especially since you've
got to be collating in your own head
every issue by definition that's your
job and you need people to come to you
with you know the level of detail
McMaster knew about the Syrian civil war
I don't think would have necessarily
helped Trump or any president make good
decisions about the Syrian civil war you
you need to know exactly what you need
to know and and it necessarily has to be
boiled down I mean by definition the
further down you go in a bureaucratic
organization like the US government the
nollet the subject matter knowledge of
the person on the you know expands the
lower they are on the totem pole but
also the breadth of what they know
shrinks dramatically right and that will
so those two lines sort of in a way meet
at the top with the president where he
has to look at the whole thing but
doesn't have time to memorize every
detail about it about everything whoever
he is and sometimes when they do
disastrous things result I mean you know
that the old stories about LBJ trying to
get right down into targeting decisions
the Vietnam War or you know Jimmy Carter
micromanaging or famous stories about
remember one of the things that that
media told us in the early 90s was the
clinton ministration was going to be
super successful is we were gonna be
wonky as president in history you knows
the details of all of this domestic
policy and such thorough detail you know
that everything is going to be a new
golden age that didn't really work out
did it no but I I would say that
President Trump gets involved in the
details of the stuff that he really
cares about and there's a story out
today it was a bit broke like at lunch
time that he personally has gone to the
Postmaster General and encouraged them
to double their rates that the rates
that they charged Amazon for deliveries
that's pretty down and we've heard that
story coming up before I left and well
it wasn't my issue area but it didn't
seem like there was anything to it then
but if there's some new information yeah
I just read the story today yeah but he
gets into the D at my point is he gets
into the details when he wants to get
into the details
doesn't everybody I mean don't you sure
don't you have to make a lot of
decisions about running a magazine that
sometimes the details you just kick down
to certain editors and then there's
stuff that you focus on intently yeah I
think I think that's fair but shouldn't
the president want to get down in the
details on something like Syria policy
should know I think he want to know that
and I wait Vicki more than he wants I
think he wants to know what do you want
I think he wants he needs to know what
he
needs to know right what's the UN what
are you court US interest in Syria I
think he knows he knows those things
think he disagrees a little bit with you
and some others about what those core
interests are he probably thinks we have
less of a core interest in Syria than
you probably do but hey there's a one
big area of agreement I know Tom I think
he's still in here somewhere and one of
the other things have been listening to
him complain about with the last three
or four years is this bizarre alliance
between certain quarters of the right
and the left that it's imperative that
the United States armed all Qaeda
affiliates to overthrow the Assad regime
which ladies and gentlemen we were going
to get that if Hillary had won the
presidency the United States was going
to be using its money and possibly its
weapons to arm people connected to the
people who blew up New York City on 9/11
as a u.s. interest well we're not going
to get that under a Donald Trump
presidency so you there something he
knows that the other side was more
walkie doesn't know yeah let's let's
shift to North Korea what what is your
sense of why the president accepted the
invitation to do this one-on-one summit
with Kim jong-un I think because there's
there's unless the United States goes to
the summit and gets hoodwinked or give
something away which I don't expect we
will there's there's no downside and a
potential upside I mean there's already
potential upside Justin accepting the
summit right it makes our allies happy
it certainly makes the South Koreans
happy makes the Japanese a little
nervous but the Japanese are divided on
this question they they're nervous
because they don't want to see us make
any concessions but they like the fact
that they're talking and so tensions go
down because you know when tensions are
up and the missiles are flying they tend
to go at or over Japan and then freaks
out Tokyo a little bit you can
understand why there yes I can
understand why they're nervous about
that so there's it's hard to see it's
hard to see a downside unless the u.s.
basically Falls for the same trick that
it's falling for in the past which is
you go to the table you talk to the
North Koreans the North Koreans say we
promised to do X and y and z if you give
us a b and c you got to give us all your
stuff for first though then well then
we'll give you the other stuff later and
we go sure you know we've done that more
than once so I'm hoping that we've done
it for 30 years I'm hoping that we've
learned our lesson I think for another
government I think president Trump
deserves credit for changing the failed
policy of the past three decades . he
deserves credit for not doing it we
outsource our policy to China on the
assumption that we had calm
interests we have overlapping interest
they are not the same interests it was a
mistake to have done it under Bill
Clinton under george w bush under Barack
Obama I think that's true isn't the
meeting itself though a concession are
we elevating no this rogue dictator
who's wanted he desperately he and his
father and grandfather have wanted a
face-to-face manner that the world's
leading superpower for him never found
that argument terribly convincing it's
only a concession if you really make a
concession the fact of the meeting
itself the fact that you're talking
doesn't seem to be a concession I mean
you know Munich was not a failure
because Chamberlain saw Hitler in person
Munich was a failure because Chamberlain
gave away the store right other meetings
can can happen you know with bad guys
can have fruitful effects you know
meeting with Stalin in Tehran and other
so good did you not believe the you know
there's a huge debate about this in the
2008 Democratic primary when Barack
Obama said happily meet with rogue
dictators anyone and everyone without
preconditions and Hillary Clinton oh
that's terrible you have to have
precondition was it your view then that
there should be no precondition we a can
meet within but we have I mean we have
tree conditions on this meeting and now
the norc's sorry we're not supposed to
say that probably anymore that's a
little National Security bureaucracy
speak the North Koreans maybe are
they're walking back the preconditions
but when they asked for the meeting
remember they're the ones who asked for
it not us right they said when we're
gonna drop our objections to joint
military exercises between the United
States and South Korea well now it's a
couple days ago they brought that up
again like maybe they object after all
you know they made certain preconditions
they said the talks will be about
denuclearization and so on we we
wouldn't be having these if this
wouldn't this is not just you know going
for tea with Kim jong-un you know they
told the South Koreans here's some stuff
that we are prepared to concede up front
to get this meeting right it would be
unrealistic to expect that you know you
denuclearize fully before we even talk
to you right that would that's too big a
concession to a realist you know to
realistically expect them to make in
advance but they did make some
preconditions and remember the meeting
is coming after a year of extraordinary
pressure on this regime they've never
been sanctioned like this before they've
never had this level of UN pressure on
them before they've never had this much
pressure for
Chinese on them before not to say that
the Chinese are maximum but their way
farther out than they've ever been
before
probably our view is or hope is that
they're really feeling the pain the
economic pain from what these sanctions
have delivered and they're probably
feeling pressure and maybe the the
potential for abandonment by their
Chinese patrons which is why they asked
for the meeting that's the way I read it
I don't think they're doing this because
they think they have a strong hand at
all you know no the North Koreans no I
certainly think that they're trying to
play they're gonna try to play the same
trick on us that they always have I mean
it would be foolish not to expect them
to do that but if they were feeling in a
strong position with great hard currency
reserves and you know the oil flowing
and all of that I don't I don't see why
do you think if obtaining nuclear
weapons was one sort of core interest of
the North Korean regime for decades the
other is the reunification of the
peninsula well the overarching core
interest is stay in power right preserve
the regime so nuclear weapons then
becomes a means to number one and
perhaps a means to number three which is
reunification on our terms but that's
you know that's a distant three it's a
pipe dream for them maybe they I don't
mean pipe dream in the sense that they
don't think it could ever achieve it but
I do think they have a sense that you
know in ranking them on terms of achieve
ability it's you know something like one
two and three is way out here before
that to happen the United States would
have to withdraw its troops we know that
that's an objective of Kim jong-un
there are news reports several of them I
find incredible that President Trump is
open to withdrawing troops defense
secretary Jim mattis said in an exchange
with reporters that that should be part
of the negotiations so a two-part
question to you one should it be part of
the negotiations and two should we do it
if you could get some kind of a deal
that formally ends the Korean War and we
know it is not over there's never been a
peace treaty that does achieve genuine
denuclearization with inspectors
crawling all over those sites undenied
anywhere something like what we've seen
in say Libya or Brazil or South Africa
countries that did denuclearize and
nobody doubts that that the denuclearize
we know it we confirmed it they might
they weren't ever caught cheating or
anything if you could get all of that
and some kind of international guarantee
I don't know exactly how this would work
but some kind of Protectorate you know
you wouldn't want to leave South Korea
totally defenseless against a
conventional North Korean assault even
if North Korea had genuinely
denuclearize because that could still
end in catastrophe or even in
reunification on the North's terms then
that could be part of the conversation
only we should rule it out in advance I
mean the only reason US troops are in
South Korea fundamentally is to prevent
a second Korean War launched by the
north if you could come up with a way to
guarantee that there could not be in
another Korean War launched by the north
then the purpose for US troops being
there would be eliminated and they could
come home is there such a thing is there
a way to get that kind of a guarantee I
mean that's gonna be a conversation
that's gonna have to take place over
years and I don't want a predict in
advance I don't it sounds hard right it
sounds really hard it sounds cuz it's
not kind of unlikely but do we want to
say it's impossible then we're gonna be
there you know then we're gonna be there
forever
so you're saying there's a chance yeah
maybe maybe
what about denuclearization is that you
know I think it is inconceivable that
the North Koreans will ever denuclearize
regardless of what they are saying today
why am I wrong
to think that the look you're right to
be skeptical but if the economic
pressure so again remember the three
priorities are regime survival then
nuclear weapon then reunification on the
north terms right if the economic
pressure is such that it begins to throw
number1 into question they might
denuclearize if it really is we can
either have this bomb that's supposed to
guarantee our security and survival but
they've they come to believe the bomb is
actually going to do the opposite it's
going to guarantee the regime collapse
because we're gonna starve to death and
go broke then maybe they would then they
would denuclearize if and that would
require us to give them a security
guarantee which is gonna cause some
people to howl why is the United States
you know basically giving a security
guarantee to an evil totalitarian regime
run by a tyrant right what would that
security guarantee look like it would
well it'd be something like you know a
recognition of the
and you know an exchange of ambassadors
I assume and a guarantee that we're not
coming team change is not a policy we're
not coming after you I would be one of
the ones howling if we gave them such a
security well the only alternative is
really then there's just status quo
forever and remember the status quo
forever if it keeps going this way we'll
be they will be nuclear arms which means
you risk that Japan will be
nuclear-armed right that South Korea
will be nuclear-armed lord knows what
happens after that but the Chinese
aren't gonna be happy about that they
could get a lot more bellicose and
adventurous because they're especially
going to be petrified by a Japanese
nuclear weapon right so the status quo
is not gonna remain either way right
right that's gonna go in a different
direction
so I I I think that would be I don't
know how achievable it is but I think
that would actually be what I just
described that you've said you would
howl about I think there'd be a
tremendously good outcome
we have disagreed before on such matters
let me describe for you my concerns
about the summit itself let's assume
that the summit takes place on June 12th
as before I'm gonna make one point here
that I haven't heard anybody else say
and I actually had an opportunity to say
it on television once and I choked so
it's my fault too
it's a victory it's a big deal that this
is going to be if it happens if the
norc's don't pull out that it happens in
Singapore that's a win for the United
States that's friendly territory for us
it's not friendly territory for them
it's sort of semi neutral for them
Singapore is all but a you know a US
ally right the North Koreans would have
wanted this in Pyongyang which of course
we were not going to do no matter what
if they couldn't get that they would
have wanted it on the border which we
didn't agree to or in China which means
in their uncle's living room or in
Ulaanbaatar or something like that which
is a wholly owned subsidiary of China
and to the extent that it isn't the
other 10% is owned by Russia
that's not favorable ground for us
either so we get it in a de-facto US
ally and a port which the US Navy visits
in an open free economy in a Western
orientation that's it that's good for us
like you know so that's a concession
that they made in order to have these
talks in a sense yeah it may be a minor
concession I think it's too strong to
call it a victory but that it leads in
perfectly to my next quite okay my
concern assuming this thing takes place
on June 12th my concern is we know that
President Trump likes to declare victory
he likes to sell
things perhaps a little bit before
they're fully ripened shall we say and I
wrote a column for the magazine about
this a couple weeks ago and pointed to
that the House Republicans having passed
the Obamacare repeal light and the White
House held a ceremony to celebrate this
momentous occasion of this pretty crumby
legislation passing one house where
Republicans had a huge majority there
was a jazz band the president gave
speeches he said that Obamacare is
almost certainly dead now yes there's
the Senate but this is the end of
Obamacare Obamacare I hope you ask here
okay I have you asking to move a knee
this question to since I don't have that
much to do with register activex with
the legislature or Obamacare but as I
understood it at the time what the
president was trying to do there was
kind of give a pep rally for the members
themselves who it was held really needed
bucking up and some public support and
some attaboys from the White House in
order to keep going so I don't think
that was exactly the motivation for that
was quite exactly as you declaring the
venturi the the president just wanted to
take an unjustified victory lap okay
well ratite purpose behind what he did
there even if there was a strategic
person what he did in effect was declare
victory and as we've heard from Tom
Joslin he's prematurely declaring
victory or coming pretty darn close to
it on Isis
my concern is he goes - to this summit
whatever comes out of the summit the we
can be certain that the president is
going to say this is a breakthrough that
it's a victory that he's done something
that no other president in history ever
has no other president in history has
done if he talks to the leader of North
Korea as you already pointed out right
but is that a victory well if it leads
to something look he I think his
language on the North Korea friend has
been entirely salt sober and responsible
so far he's talked about a willingness
to walk away if necessary he said as the
North Koreans have sort of become shaky
about whether they want the meeting to
go through at all he said I think the
meeting would be great if it were to
happen but if it doesn't happen that's
okay also called Kim jong-un on Iran oil
and
no I know what you're gonna say - we can
have it yeah because it's you're not
you're leaving out the context there's
something you complained about in the
last segment giveaway you'd provide the
community the other contact what amen I
was asked about the discussions the
president was asked about the
discussions in setting up the talks and
he says in discussing you know the
details of these talks he has been open
and honorable he didn't say he's an open
and honorable man he's an open an
honorable leader he's an open and
honorable you know steward of his
people's best interests but people went
8 and I thought you know first of all
the criticism was Trump's bellicose
rhetoric and all of these sanctions and
Rocketman are gonna get us into a war on
the Korean Peninsula this crazy man is
gonna get us into a war on the Korean
Peninsula and the oh by the way the
crazy man is low on shooting the Rockets
it's the other guy so okay that
immediately turns on a dime - this crazy
man wants to talk to the crazy man
shooting the Rockets and that's going to
lead to some terrible thing - well wait
a minute if we don't if we want to
reduce tensions and solve this problem
in a peaceful way you got to talk to
them and if you have to talk to them you
have to meet with them and discuss the
details of the talks in good faith you
know you have to do that and in doing
that you know if there are acting in
good faith about the timing and the
location and the duration and the in the
setting and all the details you know
saying that they're acting in good faith
is a reasonable thing to say it doesn't
mean that you're endorsing the regime
blessing him there's some kind of
philosopher king yeah I didn't get the
context quite the way you did
he said as as far as we've seen as far
as we've been an honor in this process
it was clear from what the question that
he got and it was it was a question that
was asked specifically about the first
Pompeo visit which was all about working
out the details of the talks right the
will will agree to I think we'll agree
to disagree on that one more broadly on
that on that question what do you hope
that he comes back with I hope well I
what I would hope he comes back with of
course he's not gonna get which is that
the North Koreans sort of decide on the
spot okay we're gonna lay there the
program put send inspectors anywhere you
want we're going to start dismantling it
but if he gets anything that moves in
that direction and he doesn't give them
any but the most minor concessions that
will have been a victory
right and this is gonna be this is gonna
be a very difficult thing to calibrate
right because the North Koreans are not
going to accept a position where you
know the United States cannot say every
sanction we've put on to the last detail
remains until full denuclearization is
completed we're gonna have to give as we
get and working out exactly how we give
as we get without giving too much and
getting too little is gonna be really
complicated and it's gonna require lots
of hard work by you know those mid-level
and upper lower-level bureaucrats who do
know the country and the nuclear program
why do I want to get off of North Korea
but I find this so interesting that we
need to keep going why do we have to
give as we get why can't because they're
not gonna they're not gonna they're not
gonna keep going isn't that what caused
us all these problems no no I know what
caused this whole concession after
concession oh what a said they would
what causes their masses that we gave
too much and got too little or got
promises and then a fulfilled our end of
the promise and they didn't fulfill
their in right this is gonna have to be
very carefully choreographed where they
give a little and we confirm that we've
gotten it we don't take their word for
it we confirm it then we give a little
then they give a little and so on and
that can go off the rails at any time
just mapping out the plan is gonna be
really complicated and then you got to
implement the plan what would happen in
before is they'd say we'll give you X
you give us Y and we okay we gave Y and
they either gave 1/10 of X or none or we
just became in curious how following up
on what we were getting and kind of let
the issue drift into the background
until some spectacular revelation came
out and it was no longer even reasonably
deniable that they had cheated right I
see I think they were they were they
were giving us stuff over here and doing
stuff over here that's another that's I
have a problem one of the reasons why
one of the things that we will have to
get to make this work is is a robust
inspections regime that's gonna have
people crawling all over both sites and
they're not gonna want to accept that so
the only reason ultimately they're going
to accept that is if they feel the
regime is threatened its existence is
threatened by the resource denial that
the sanctions provide let me move to a
couple of sort of Trump Whitehouse
questions generally and then we'll
finish on flight 93 big-picture stuff
Reince Priebus when he left the White
House said that in effect
what you read in the newspapers what you
see in the media it's 50 times more
chaotic than that yes you right what
look his perch was a lot higher than
mine right closer to the Oval no
question about it he saw more of the
president he saw more of everything I
had in my niche I mean it was the
National Security Council I it went
through its trials and tribulations but
it's settled in and it got pretty
orderly and I think what we delivered to
the president were some you know strong
options and some policies that he chose
that were well rolled out and fairly
orderly so I would not my own experience
I would not describe as 50 times or even
two times more chaotic than what you saw
from the outside the mic warned this
morning on the panel described the the
back and forth on the Iran deal and the
imaginations that went there which were
were a little but the president changed
his mind several times he wasn't getting
the advice that he wanted to get is it
possible was apartment one of things you
had to do as deputy national security
adviser communications strategic
communications it is it how challenging
was it to rule out a policy when you
have a president who does make he's an
ad hoc decision maker there's no denying
he didn't he the the Rand Paul so
there's - first of all we have to
separate the deal the nuclear deal from
the Iran policy so the administration
developed a comprehensive around policy
that we rolled out in October and it was
tied to but not you know concomitant
with the deal there was one of the
tragedy and there's so many tragedies to
the Iran deal but one of the tragedies
of the Iran deal is that it consumed all
of the thinking and work of the entire
US government on Iran was just looking
at this deal you know it was a complete
waste of everybody's time and energy for
so long
nonetheless we managed we managed to put
together a comprehensive and ran
strategy that the president rolled out
very effectively in an orderly way in
October and that's still being
implemented right and so on the deal
itself
look what I've say about that and have
said elsewhere is this president who
campaigned so hard against it and yet
stayed in it for 16 months right so far
from being impulsive and ad-hoc you know
he allowed every
chants for people for the the US
government but especially European
allies to see what they could get to fix
the deal over and over again
despite his clear sort of gut impulse to
just let him walk
you know he kept letting people try and
try and try and try until finally he
just said it's enough it's been - it's
been long enough we're not getting where
we need to go the sticking point
apparently was that the Europeans were
willing to do everything that the
president had asked for it except the
sunset clause which is completely
idiotic right it's not you know you
don't get a nuke for ten years all of it
after 10 years yeah have at it I mean
that just makes absolutely no sense to
me at all but they were hard over on
that point because they felt that the
Iranians wouldn't stick to it if the
Iranians wouldn't stick to it it means
the commercial relations between the
Europeans and the Iranians wouldn't be
what they want it was kind of all about
well it wasn't all about the money
really I think there are two things
motivating the Europeans one it was the
money they wanted to do business with
Iran they had for a long time but -
there's a real undercurrent of domestic
political opinion in these countries
especially in Germany that you know we
the United States is the problem Iran's
not really a problem so if you help
Trump strengthen the Iran deal that's
that's bad right you know you don't give
Trump a political wind I could you spend
at the expense of the noble
long-suffering Iranian people and by the
way I would agree with that point of the
Iranian people are long-suffering but
the deal is with the regime it's not
with the people and the people you know
that they're ruled by a theocracy so you
can't you can't make that distinction so
easily do you um last question on this
do you Tom Jocelin has talked about the
administration getting too far ahead on
Isis on its language on Isis yeah you
obviously think highly of Tom mm-hmm is
he right about that
look I have taken my cues from him on
these matters for a very very very long
time I can only say that this is not
simply the president who's using this
rhetoric I mean he's getting this from
his commanders and I would also say he
and I can argue about this I'm sure he
would win the argument because he would
just come up with facts that I don't
know and I'd run out of things to rebut
with pretty quickly but you know the
president my experience was was careful
- you know and we in helping him craft
his language we were tried to be careful
and saying we've destroyed the physical
caliphate but there's still a
five-figure number of
fighters out there that in Syria and
elsewhere and in Iraq you know the the
territorial control is down to almost
zero the resource control they don't
have oil fields anymore they don't have
cities they don't have Raqqa they don't
have Mosel they don't have this they
don't have that right and I can you know
as a personal anecdote there was one
occasion not that so shortly before I
left so fairly recently when we had to
put out statement on something I wrote
it I walked it in to show it to the
president and he was the one who took
out some line of mine that he thought
went too far in taking credit and I said
ah you know what you know why don't you
want to get a little more you know more
credit for this this was kind of a
promise fulfilled and he said I don't
yeah I'm not sure we're there yet and if
this starts to come back everybody was
gonna point back to this line and say so
you were the problem I was part of the
problem it's a really big admission yeah
so moving now to the to the bigger
picture Trump presidency trumpism flight
93's a in in that flight 93's a you
described trumpism has secure borders
economic nationalism and America first
foreign policy is Donald Trump 17 months
in giving America trumpism well so I was
somebody asked me this the other day and
it was some cash I thought it was such
an original question it was a private
conversation but they they phrased it if
such like you know do we think the
president has failed or has he done
anything wrong and I said you know the
only thing that I could even conceive of
criticizing the president for is just
not giving us enough Trump right so I'd
like there to be more wall right now I
wish we could go faster on the wall on
reforming immigration and I understand
that there are you know obstacles to
that many of which I described in
somewhat cutting detail in the flight 93
election including a court of yoona
party ruling class that absolutely does
not want to secure the border and will
undercut any effort to do so and has
been undercut cutting any effort to do
so for the last 30 or 40 years so I
would like to see more in that direction
and I don't think the reason we haven't
gotten more is you know because Trump
doesn't want to do those things it's
because the it's kind of extraordinary
confluence of
factors or forces standing away in this
agenda they're still standing there you
don't just win one election in 2016 and
the left says okay well we give up yeah
we're you you guys want it's cool do
whatever you want you know the the the
the Conservatives or the the Republicans
I put conservatives in quotes who have
always stood against these kinds of
impulses they don't just give up and go
away they keep fighting everything that
that Trump had to fight against in 2016
to get here is still fighting him now so
I'd like to see more progress on all of
those things I'm not exactly shocked
that we haven't seen as much as I would
have wanted to know he's probably been a
little bit more engaged on the foreign
policy front than than we might have
guessed when you wrote that essay no
possibly I I didn't see yeah I didn't
see the North Korea thing coming that is
the sense I didn't I didn't really
anticipate that North Korea would gin up
all these activities in such a way that
they would because they had been quiet
for a while you know there we went a
long time without testing a missile and
then they I think around April started
up again in earnest and then tested like
crazy all throughout the rest of the
year yeah that was you know somewhat of
a surprise at least to me what Fred
Barnes has a good column in last week's
Weekly Standard making the case that one
of the president's biggest
accomplishments is simply undoing Barack
Obama's main accomplishments he included
the Iran deal there the repeal of the
individual mandate other parts of
Obamacare is his because other critics
would say much of what he's done can
easily be reversed because he's done it
just himself deregulated because he sits
in the Oval Office he's legislatively
hasn't done much beyond tax reform is
that a fair criticism it's it's a fair
observation but you know if he could
have gotten legislatively and a repeal
to Obamacare he certainly wanted it and
why couldn't he get it because of the
same Republican Party that I was griping
about in the flight 93 election in the
Journal of American greatness did what
it does best it got together after
saying for years we're going to appeal
this as soon as we are back in power and
then as soon as they have the chance to
do it they sell out their voters and
they go back on their word does he not
have any blame for the
of Obamacare kill Obamacare I suppose if
we're gonna get down to the granularity
of apportioning blame there might be
something there but would you say it's
above 50% or even above 20% well I think
I mean if you talk to Republican
lawmakers including people I think we
both would regard as conservatives
movement conservatives not the swamp
they would say that one of the things
that hurt them and their ability to pass
Obamacare repeal was repeal was the
president's inability to grasp the
details of this and his public
statements and tweets that undercut
sometimes what they were doing after the
House passed the bill that we talked
about he said it was a mean bill I don't
I don't deny that people tell you that
and they probably really believe it but
but if if the ability to get legislation
passed is to have one man the elected
magistrate of 300 chief magistrate of
320 million people who has to keep ten
thousand balls in the air at all times
if it comes down to him understanding
the nuances and details of a 2,000 page
or however long it is giant doorstop
that the most dedicated health care
expert can barely read without em feta
means than we are truly dead I would
suggest you might be overstating
slightly what the what the problem was
the president has a big role to play in
in making that case and for the people
who actually cared about the details of
the policy they wanted him to play that
role
they wanted him to understand that the
broad argument is that I mean I mean at
the end of the day the decisive moment
was when the Republicans could not stand
together and vote for something they
said they always wanted to get rid of
something the American people never said
they wanted and in fact actively opposed
and you know seemed to despise I would
say that was one of the decisive moments
the other decisive moment came with with
Rand Paul and president drum deciding
that they were going to do repeal and
replace together at the same time and
they tweeted that okay the president
tweeted it yeah only tweets all hot heat
test we arrived
what it so what about the tweets they
did how many times how many times did
they send you scrambling did you you
you're sitting there and you've got you
okay I'm gonna go into work today I'm
gonna sit down
I've got this plan I'm gonna do these
memos I'm going to talk to these
reporters I'm gonna do this and then
look I'm the wrong person to ask this in
the sense that I'm conflicted I'm not a
Twitter fan I'm not on it I think I was
on it under my pseudonym Decius for like
three months and then when the journal
American greatness went away I went away
maybe a little longer than that but it
wasn't very long I will never get back
on it please hold me to that so all I
can say is like it works for him it's
his style I'm a long-winded guy I like
to write big long essays 280 characters
hems me in a bit much I came to write a
sentence in 280 words so Twitter in the
years are just oil oil and water so I
will I don't think Mulvaney is here
today he was like not me might have left
he was here here here but he's not I
think with us so I'm gonna ask you one
of he was he was he was here I think he
left out
he was I saw him over there for about 20
minutes okay we may have bored him at
possible let me ask you a question I
haven't asked him one of the finding the
biggest challenges facing the country is
debt deficit entitlement reform the
president opposes entitlement reform he
campaigned against entitlement reform
thinking it's a pretty dramatic change
from where the Republican Party was it
we will not reduce our national debt
without reforming entitlements what
we're gonna have to find a way to reform
entitlements in a way that doesn't
convince working-class blue-collar you
know low and middle income Americans in
the heartland and spelt and so on that
these are the green eyeshade Republicans
coming after you in order to increase
essentially income inequality and wealth
concentration and that was the failure
you call that a failure the message you
can call it a failure of past policies
maybe it's both but it was definitely a
failure for the message at a minimum
of the Republican Party in the twenty to
thirty years that precedes how do you
make that case it's I have your
messaging guy had it yeah when you word
the top levels of the White House I'm
one on a narrow band of topics and this
was not one of them isn't it the reality
that it's bad news and you have to tell
people it's bad news okay we're gonna
have to find a way to solve it that
either isn't and hopefully the minimum
doesn't sound like and hopefully also
isn't what you know Mitt Romney was
trying to sell and what others who have
studied this carefully have been trying
to sell because what it sounds like to
you know Roseanne is okay so you know
these things that are like keeping me
and maybe my cousins and uncles and
grandparents stuff alive and got through
hard times now you're coming to take
those away too
and where is that all where's all that
gonna go some you know ninety story
condo building in Manhattan again like
really is this country just going to
keep going in this direction forever
until until we're all completely broken
and forgotten the Republicans just they
don't know how to talk to those people
at all and I don't think they know how
to devise solutions that actually help
those people they've gotten so convinced
it that you know the solutions of 1980
are valid for all time we have 21
trillion dollars in debt isn't it time
that we stop worrying about how to sell
particular policies to particular no
groups and and say this is a big enough
problem we have to actually address it
head-on in a serious because if we can't
we're not gonna win any elections so the
dead then the Democrats also for their
own reasons don't have any interest in
solving the entire one problem so on
your own terms it'll just get worse and
then we'll have all the other attendant
problems that's my goods being involved
that's my concern you now have both
Republicans and Democrats opposed to
entitlement reform when it's the one
thing that we know will has any chance
of reducing the national debt well as I
say I'm all for finding a way to deal
with it but we got to find a way to deal
with it that doesn't sort of either seem
to or actively does sellout the
interests of the core coalition that
that trump has put together look it was
I think this essay first appeared in the
Weekly Standard that eventually became
the book Grand Old Party right in it the
point of it the point of the essay was
to say
and so basically not delivered anything
for their core voters right you know
working rural and middle-class people in
the heartland in the rough boat for a
generation they've not done anything for
these people and these people keep
voting for them anyway out of a negative
case because they know that the left
really hates them and wants to come
after them but it boy wouldn't it
imagine how much good the Republican
Party could do and how much electoral
success it might have if it actually
started delivering something for that
core constituency and just saying we're
gonna come in we're going to take away
all your benefits that that's not gonna
that's not going to do it well at some
point we're gonna have to do those
reforms I mean you can you can make a
case that Republicans should do a better
job of telling people what they're going
to give them know they also we don't
have the money to keep giving okay as a
country why I agree with that we don't
forever have the money to keep giving
it's a country but we we don't also have
really the love aren't you then just
deceiving them if you say if you don't
level with them I mean are you then
saying look we don't want to take
anything away we're gonna we're gonna
deliver on what I mean it's basically
the bargain that you're proposing is the
Republican Party goes to those voters
that I'm describing and says hey you
feel kind of poor and like you've been
stuck in neutral or even going backwards
for the last three years we're gonna
make you a lot poorer vote for us now
that way I don't think that would
probably be the most effective campaign
argument you do I'm making a much I'm my
proposition much simpler we're 21
trillion dollars in debt we've had
politicians say that we're going to
address this for years we had for a
short time a Republican Party that
literally voted on entitlement reform in
their budgets year after year after year
and in what I take is one of their a few
acts of political courage in recent
American history in Washington and we've
now just abandoned it well one would in
a way one thing that will make this case
easier to make is which we're seeing now
although we've only been seeing it for
that year is a tighter labor market
rising wages prosperity more evenly
spread through sectors of the economy
and geographically through the country
and not concentrated and the blue dots
on the coast
and in the tech sector and financial
services and stuff like that you know
and those are the kind of things that
that trumpian economic policy and his
own political instincts are trying to
pursue and deliver if that works for a
while 5-10 years it's gonna be a lot
easier to go back and make the political
case for entitlement reform but just
doing it now like well you've sort of
felt like you've been going down and now
we're gonna take you to here immediately
that's not gonna get you anywhere okay
if we've got five years I think we'll be
lucky I would argue that a trade war
might complicate some of the projections
that you're made I mean a trade trade
horse a slogan and that annoys me just
because it's been used as a cudgel
anytime you want to do anytime you want
to address change and do anything about
countries that you know who use rip
trade war who the president okay
trade wars are good and trade wars easy
to win he did he did so he's supposed to
be going somewhere or doing something no
it's a are you trying to cut us off okay
the water was rising in here if if
tipped air I just you know if tariffs
were the worst thing in the history of
the world
I don't understand how the United States
was able to accomplish anything
economically from the end of the Civil
War
until World War one I don't think that
the worst thing in the history of the
world but free trade has done a lot of
good the free trade free trade has done
a lot of good for the country and
circumstances in which free trade works
when free trade becomes synonymous with
basically hollowing out industries and
communities to the benefit of other
countries to the detriment of our own
it's no longer doing as much good it's
certainly enriching certain people in
certain sectors of the United States
economy and has but you can't say that
it's spread that spread its benefits
widely in the last 20 years the way it
did from say 1945 to 1975 well I would
say over overall if you look at never
that's always a trade
well Adam Smith Adam Smith was right you
think Adam Smith was wrong no actually
since you asked and how you're gonna go
to the Theory of Moral Sentiments no I'm
not going to go to the theory Moral
Sentiments when I was writing the
journal of American greatness I had
occasion to go back pick up Smith read
through it again Smith and Ricardo and
they don't actually make the case that
you're
what they say is all things being equal
between two more or less equivalent
economies with two more or less
equivalently industrious talented
people's and so on between say England
and France if one has a comparative
advantage and textiles and the other has
a comparative advantage and you know
whatever one guar wine right it will
even itself out but the the the that
does not that analogy does not apply to
a developed high wage economy
essentially being preyed on to an
undeveloped low wage economy that's
deliberately setting policy to destroy
whole economic sectors in this country
over here it doesn't even itself out
over time even if the economic aggregate
of both goes up right then the the net
the net rise if it isn't distributed
equally in this country here is going to
cause a lot of pain and political
heartache and other things and it you
know once industries are gone in this
country over here that also becomes a
national security risk you know and you
can't build a fighter jet in the United
States anymore without all kinds of
steel and parts from China oh you know
do you really want the Chinese having
really much of anything to do with the
US defense industry I don't well I don't
know I mean the the president the other
day yeah the president the other day so
that he was worried about Chinese jobs
and we should no no no no we should walk
back he's pointed out that in a
particular company there are particular
company that the US intelligence
community has warned about for years in
which the Commerce Department has gone
after mm-hmm because they violate
sanctions on North Korea in Iran he said
we should not put them out of business
he said we would hurt them he asked the
Secretary of Commerce to study it in
part based on the US jobs component in
the supply chain to that company it
doesn't mean he's gonna reverse
necessarily a the stuff that you're
talking about we're gonna have to wait
and see what the Commerce Department
tells him and I hope he doesn't and what
he what he said he was going to do he
didn't say he was gonna do anything
except look at it said he was gonna
revisit revisit it yeah yeah
after his call was she yeah what do you
do when somebody calls you up that
you're trying to make a deal with and
says you know what I really need I
really need this you can shut him down
right then or you can say alright I'll
take a look at it well I've never been
in a position when the person on the
other end of the line was a and
explained
this communist dictator for life who is
selling me on expansionist would be on
telecommunications I'm their spawn as
much of a China hawk and a lot of
respects as anybody but if there's one
thing they're not they're not really
expansionist mmm-hmm and where are they
going to expand I mean they got the
Himalayas here they've got the hydrogen
that's there beyond immediate territory
well let's let's end on a point where I
know we'll agree and that's the
character question we've argued about
quite a bit yeah one thing we've seen
over the the course of really Donald
Trump's entry into the race and then the
Trump administration is a very different
view from a lot of conservatives on this
question of character conservatives made
the argument when Bill Clinton was
president he was a man of poor character
it would affect his private behavior
would affect the way that he carries out
his public duties and you have a lot of
conservatives making precisely the
opposite case today is it just at this
point anachronistic to worry about the
character of our national leaders no I
wouldn't say that at all and I don't
know that anyone ever made the argument
that we shouldn't worry about the
character of our national leaders in the
final and now you worry about Donald
Trump's character why worry about it no
I don't worry about it
do you think he's a man of good
character I think he's a man with many
virtues and many of those virtues were
absolutely apt and necessary to the
situation we found ourself in 2016 and
continue to find ourselves in now for
instance I mean look let's face it to
run on securing the border on doing
something about trade and unpicked the
issues he's picked he basically took on
all of conventional wisdom of both
parties you know almost the entire donor
class of the Republican Party the
intellectual consensus left and right
because you're basically with the left
on all of this stuff - right you are on
those issues and he won which later on
which is on immigration on trade free
trade the things that Donald Trump where
he where he broke with a right used to
be pretty strongly in favor of free
trade
go ahead that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying so he's going he's
essentially aligned himself with the old
left wrong trade right right but
against Yuna party consensus and he has
been vilified and it's orated it takes a
person of unusual courage and fortitude
to put yourself forward to that when you
don't have to and just take the abuse of
essentially I mean and it gets he gets
the abuse domestically foreign I mean
okay let's see let's regulate that he
has virtues nobody had to do that he
ever did is and he's displayed character
that he's displayed courage he has
virtues he's displayed courage do you
think he's a man of good character he
also as displayed foresight I mean it
took it took us like thirty years I'll
stipulate care or a reportage to come
along and virtues floor site he's to
make the case to make the the succinct
case he's lied about Rafael Cruz he's we
believe had an affair with a porn star
hey you're by for money but I haven't
the faintest idea whether he did her
doing yeah but and he says he didn't so
I and I just don't see what else I said
he didn't reimburse Michael Cohen for
the payments the payments never happened
I mean there's a we don't need to get
bogged down on the actual specifics of
that I feel pretty confident even if I
look look Steve even if I were
stipulated that I would still say to you
like I would assert like I'd still
rather have a wall and a strong foreign
policy and also not Hillary Clinton
running the Justice Department and these
agencies coming after me and everything
I believe in I I mean look I'm gonna do
the answer to my question is yes I have
not yet renews that gonna be on another
high minded reference that I'm kind of
known for so I'm just bring up Plutarch
right you know the Plutarch finds a lot
wanting and some of the the people that
he analyzes some of the things you're
talking about he doesn't care about that
much because they don't matter that much
to the exigencies at the moment so the
answer to my question the I character is
it really is anachronistic these things
don't matter a lot of the policies are
not anachronistic but I mean are the
things that you're talking about
assuming they're all true which again I
am NOT stipulating I'm just assuming
they're all true are they not outweighed
by the the virtues that you're
stipulating to me especially given what
we need in this moment I think that I
think that you can have a balance I mean
I think I'm okay well you gotta fight
you know you can't have a balance but do
you I mean when you vote you binary
choice unfortunately in this country
mmm so I had a candidate not a binary I
had a candidate who wanted to do things
that I have thought needed doing for in
my own head I had come to conclusions
over the course of 10 or 15 years of
these things needed to be doing and the
people who the very few people who ever
ran on those issues got absolutely
nowhere finally somebody comes along and
he puts them together which nobody yet
had done and he is successful right and
you know over Michael :
you're supposed to tell me that I should
have liked not voted or voted for
Hillary Clinton and not buy-in I'm not
telling you you should have voted for
Hillary Clinton that's all right I know
men are written in that whoever union
for you to kick down this whatever is
not like not whatever you want it to be
it's for Harry Wright in Mickey Mouse
not vote whatever but definitely you
know can't vote for Trump like that's
not the way I saw it and I made my
argument at the time and I don't have
any reason reason looking back to regret
it
well I think that's 356 we are done
thank you very much for coming let me
let me just say one word you can tell
why Mike and I have these events and why
they sometimes go on for four hours we
go sometimes bicker like an old married
couple but I enjoy it and I think it's
good to do and I'm especially glad that
you came here to make the case and have
the argument so and he's around all
weekend so if you didn't get questions
[Applause]